the liberal media taking a mallet to
someone who isn't even on the ballot an
MSNBC panel viciously attacking Florida
first lady Casey DeSantis after she hit
the campaign Trail for her husband
Casey DeSantis is a fairly compelling
political figure in Florida and now
nationally for many she's the brighter
side to Florida's angry governor for
others she's become America's Karen
America's Karen David Jones well I
called her I called her this you know
Serena Waterford wannabe needs to cut it
out there's all kinds of names for her
she needs to stop trying to measure the
great drapes in the White House and
think that she's some kind of Jackie O
reincarnate I mean Casey DeSantis keep
an eye on her though she's a Wily figure
what a bunch of Mean Girls
okay Rod DeSantis says the left is just
threatened by his wife
my wife is an incredibly strong first
lady of Florida a fantastic mother and a
great wife and that threatens the left I
think that they're very worried about
her Effectiveness and so all that's
doing is confirming that she's over the
target we wear criticism from MSNBC as a
badge of honor
this is not the first time the Press
completely trashed the Florida first
lady last month The Daily Beast labeled
her the Walmart Melania and Politico
portrayed her as a Lady Macbeth type
character who is governor desantis's
greatest liability Harold we were in The
Green Room we were discussing this at
length and you said something that
really struck me you said the only
reason why those fools at MSNBC make fun
of her is because she's hotter than they
are and like all the Republican women
tend to be just gorgeous but you look on
the liberal side there are hideous
horrible monsters like you often see on
MSNBC that's exactly what you said to me
I was shocked I was murmuring that under
my breath how did you hear all that the
uh look I grew up in a time in politics
where families were off limits spouses
were off limits in campaigns and I think
over the last many years we've seen more
and more of it come back I don't I don't
I don't condone anything that's been
upset about her uh it has been said that
Mrs DeSantis is an advisor to her
husband I think if someone wants to
point out policy decisions choices that
Governor DeSantis has made not that his
wife may have advisable and that's where
the that's where the focus the focus
should be one of our in-house newspapers
The Wall Street Journal wrote over the
weekend how China controls most of the
world's most important minerals and how
that will enable them and Empower their
economy over the next several years
that's that's what we should be talking
about and I hope that the name calling
which happens on both sides honestly
this instance here I'm not trying to
downplay it or belittle it or for that
matter even diminish the importance of
it I hope any network that talks about
any one spouse just stops it if you want
to talk about that candidate talk about
that candidate talk about the things
he's doing one day we'll say she is a
president may have not done her his or
her job if you want to talk about
President Biden talk about him not his
wife or his spouse and the same should
be true with Governor DeSantis unless
she's a doctor like Dr chill
right judge by the way judge didn't it
strike you when we're watching that that
like
MSNBC male female whatever a very
misogynistic right they're like that you
got a really mean girl Vibe you get that
from The View too they act like they're
pro-women unless you disagree with them
and then they Rippy The shreds because
you're not their kind of woman they're
haters yeah they're just haters These
are the people who are all inclusive
they want to get everyone Under the Tent
because we accept everyone and you
better accept everyone and if you don't
you're out and they're the ones who are
the haters they hated Melania I mean she
was one of the most beautiful first
ladies you've ever had she was I hated
her and Casey DeSantis I mean I've met
her on many occasions she is beautiful
she is smart she is charming she's a
breast cancer survivor uh she's very uh
involved in her husband's career and you
know that's a good thing she loves him
and the truth is that she is someone who
I think is going to make a difference in
the campaign because she is smart and
she's formally worked on television I
believe for a short period of time she
is a uh she is a positive and they can't
deal with it it makes them crazy Dana we
were talking about this in the break uh
this is actually real
[Laughter]
just the phrase Karen is so
2022. they are 2021 it's even like it's
like it was it came out kind of like
before the before the lockdowns and and
the fact that they chuckle at that it
does show you that they're living in
kind of like a an old world uh that they
found that kind of like humorous that
fellow in the middle I can't think of
his name Cape face yes so not only that
but when they in The Daily Beast when
they said uh she is a Walmart Melania
yes that's not an attack against Casey
DeSantis or Melania Trump that's an
attack against the Walmart shoppers
which is also an attack against the
deplorable so where do we have that to
think from you know they they can think
Hillary Clinton for that but that's what
they really think I'm surprised at how
much time the media spends going after
what she looks like what he looks like
what his face looks like when he laughs
what they wear and not about his
policies but I think one of the reasons
is because a major parental rights issue
is at the top motivating factors for
people right now because even people on
the moderate Democratic left are saying
wait they really think the government
should be taking care of our children
they don't want that and the governor
has been very successful in Florida
trying to bring that to a sensible side
of things and I think that they're
concerned about that or they should be
Jesse let's inject race into this shall
we that's my specialty yes that's true
uh we we've we've often we brought I
think we were the first people to
mention the word Karen until we realized
that it was racist yeah right it's only
for white people well it is
Karen is a a nosy obnoxious
white Suburban mom who gets in
everyone's business right I don't see
Casey doing any of that have you I
haven't seen her say anything do
anything act annoying act busy buddy
call the manager that I mean Jeff
Jonathan Capehart sounds more like that
than she does right is that the guy in
the middle yeah I think he could be a
Karen
I'm not gonna
yes but Casey DeSantis is fair game yeah
come on and if you're getting compared
to Jackie O and Melania I'd take that as
a win Hillary was the political spouse
that the media loved remember that she
was a joke she inserted herself into
everything and she was more caring than
anybody and they fell behind her but
yeah Casey who takes care of the kids
she's beautiful she's out on the stump
making sense she's like the perfect
political spouse and that's the threat
because they know how powerful she is
you can't spell Karen without Karen
their biggest sin is that they care and
we've turned that into a flaw and you
can't spell America without care
is there anything else no that's good
okay thank you I had great a Grace
concert goers early junk at their
favorite pop stars I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now